I don't have a lot of Records
I did the best I could and I have a lot
of great friends and I had a good time
wonderful time but I don't have a lot of
Burt Reynolds has died at the age of 82
he can confirm the actor went into
cardiac arrest at a hospital in Florida
on September 6th then that his family
was by his side
I had concerns that if the humanity of
the people could be brought out you know
and for me I was the father knows best
of his dog film world so I wasn't
participating if you will Reynolds was
part of around 90 films over his career
no I don't tell me let me guess
including Boogie Nights and perhaps his
most iconic role it's my dream to make a
film that's true
I'm right he was slated to be part of
Quentin Tarantino's upcoming film Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood alongside Brad
Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio Edie's last
interview with Burt was in March at the
premiere of his movie the last movie
star an audience for forgive the egg -
she's been Wow in act 3 the film was
written for him the director just told
me when you screened it for the first
time that you cried like a baby
why how did it make you feel were you
emotional obviously no I'm not that
emotional about it but tonight I might
be how do you feel like Hollywood has
treated you over the years I'm still
here you told ET a few years back we sat
down with you and you said you've
experienced a lot of highs but also a
lot of lows in your career what is that
and what would you say was the biggest
hype when I was number one in the world
for five years in a row that was play
you've been a trailblazer in this
industry you've been a trailblazer
you've been a sex symbol you've been
labeled so many things what label
resonates the most with you well being
here at this time in my life and you
know I didn't think it would last this
long - you've done a hundred films you
stole more to go how do you do it what
keeps you going
how do you stay healthy and in shape
it's amazing well people like you
they're nice and pretty
that doesn't to be more than that though
right it helps so
[Music]